[Music]
Super Smash Brothers is a game that
means a lot of things to a lot of people
it's the ultimate party game it's the
peak of competition and most importantly
it's a community for two decades smash
has brought people together it's a
crossover filled with characters
everyone recognizes but also a game that
can bring casual players together with
their competitive counterparts and those
competitive players have taken the game
far beyond what it was initially meant
to be they've evolved the game and
created something new something that can
last the test of time continue to bring
people together and can hold up the
community Super Smash Brothers is much
more than just a game and this is its
story
[Applause]
Masahiro Sakurai is one of Nintendo's
greatest success stories at 19 years old
he created Kirby while working for
Nintendo partner how laboratory and over
the next few years developed the
character and a series into one of
Nintendo's core franchises but Sakurai
was ambitious he devoured games for
research when trying to come up with his
next project and ended up spending a lot
of time in arcades there he found
himself drawn to competitive fighting
games like Street Fighter 2 and the King
of Fighters 95 one day while playing KOF
at the arcade Sakurai was faced with an
opponent whose skills left a lot to be
desired
it was only after demolishing them that
he realized what he had just done his
opponents were a young couple who had
just popped into the arcade to try some
new games and Sakurai
uh nya lated them furthermore the game
itself didn't do the young couple any
favors it wasn't easy to understand and
the second they sat down to play they
were faced with an expert opponent
Sakurai was disappointed in himself and
the shock led him to come up with a new
kind of fighting game one where the
skill floor was lower where it would be
harder for an incredible player to
completely destroy their opponent the
game was Dragon King the fighting game a
pitch developed by Sakurai and his
mentor Satoru Iwata Dragon King was a
battle royale
for player fighting game without health
bars so that players could keep fighting
even after they took a beating but when
he pitched it to Nintendo's executives
Sakurai asked to replace Dragon Kings
generic martial artists with Nintendo's
all-stars after a few months of
development Super Smash Brothers was
released on in 10 to 64 which sold over
a million coffees in Japan and 5.5
million worldwide the game itself was a
first entry in a brand new genre
something no one had ever seen before
word of mouth spread quickly as the
sales picked up guaranteeing its success
but its incredible success meant that
Nintendo
wanted a sequel for their upcoming
GameCube console and they wanted it in
13 months Sakurai has described the year
of work he did on super smash bros melee
as one of the worst times of his life he
lived in his office and oversaw every
aspect of development the game itself
was designed with more mechanics in
place for hardcore players to help great
players distinguish themselves but the
game was also a better experience for
casual players with more single-player
modes collectable trophies and more
stages items and characters to play with
it was huge and something that Sakurai
himself still calls the sharpest entry
in the series and the one most suited to
competitive play
[Applause]
it was also an instant success the game
sold a million copies in two months
making it the first GameCube game to do
so by the end of its lifespan it sold
over seven million copies and is the
best-selling GameCube game of all time
with nearly a third of all GameCube
owners having a copy
the birth of competitive melee can be
traced back to Northern California's
tournament go series where Matthew matt
deezie Dahlgren hosted melee tournaments
at his house and set the first
competitive rule sets in stone most
smash fans played the same way on any
stage and with items on sure some people
preferred stock or time and some maniacs
like coin matches but in the end no
matter who you played with you were
getting a similar melee experience but
people competing at the very first melee
tournaments around the u.s. slowly put
together a rule set that banned items
and certain stages to reduce the impact
of randomness on a match by 2004 the
commonly accepted tournament rule set
banned all items and used a small
selection of available stages though
that rule set was far from the one we
see today
as the years went on the stage list got
pared down and the rule set got stricter
allowing just six of the games
twenty-nine stages on top of that a meta
game developed that favored specific
characters leading to the creation of
tearless that saw characters like fox
falco chic and of course Marth on top
combo seven comes with a convincing Ken
combo and takes chilling down I
seriously to outsiders this seemed
insane why throw away so much of the
game why remove items limit stages and
tell people that most of their favorite
characters were effectively unplayable
because the game was ment to be played
casually there were no shortage of memes
that poked fun at the competitive melee
community I challenge you to a game of
Smash Brothers what's this no items fox
only final destination but the
excitement around the competitive scene
was spreading many traditional fighting
game fans gave melee a look and found
that it was surprisingly similar to
games like Street Fighter and Marvel vs.
Capcom so the first game I was looking
for was obviously ball vs. Capcom 2 and
I played like three games at the time I
was playing melee guilty gear for games
I was playing melee kill to get that
second Marvel to the Marvel tool was
always the one that caught my attention
the most competitive melee was young in
2007 and many of the techniques we
associate with the game today weren't
yet invented but players still put on
incredible performances showing a game
that was faster than many fighting games
but simple enough for everyone to
understand however there was one thing
that was the same Nintendo didn't give
the competitive community the time of
day
Nintendo's kind of been very much the
opposite and where they don't really
embrace in the competitive communities
at all they're difficult to even get
streaming rights like we haven't even
asked him for like TVs money anything
like just can we show this game that we
believe in that you created stream it
for our professional events and they
reluctant even to that the earliest
legends of melee fought for dominance
and carved out a legacy that would
inspire later melee players
congratulations to PC Chris he came in
at beginning of the season stunned
everyone by beating Ken he outlast
everyone else he's gonna take home
$10,000 and be crowned the national
champion of Super Smash Brothers really
incredible and as the years went on a
new generation of players arrived on the
scene younger players who pushed melee
further than ever before
guys like you - King mango and Armada
all rose to prominence and showed off
what competitive melee could be but
their rise was tempered by the
announcement of a new smash game there's
one more title I guess I should mention
that will turn that fight into an
absolute brawl
by 2005 Sakurai was hard at work on a
new smash game for a nintendos next
console that was going to be bigger
better and include support for
Nintendo's nascent Wi-Fi network for
online player and trust me it's the best
Smash Brothers ever by far Super Smash
Bros Brawl was going to be a staple for
the Wii and the same way that melee was
for the Gamecube and in order to get
people interested it promised
third-party characters a story mode of
animated cutscenes and more content than
any smash game ever had Super Smash
Brothers Brawl is average if you intend
to play it by yourself as a multiplayer
game it nears perfection though the
Subspace Emissary is a disappointment
the fast-paced fighting bountiful modes
and customization options and a deep set
of hidden content to be unearthed give
it staying power that few other games
258 songs 41 stages 35 characters a
level editor the story mode collectible
trophies and stickers even demos of
games that some smash characters debuted
it was unprecedented it was enormous and
it's sold like crazy to this day
brawl remains the single best-selling
smash game of all time
with over 13 million coffees sold and
was critically acclaimed but for the
hardcore melee fans there were problems
it didn't Wow me like right off the bat
and I was kind of worried about that at
least from it at least from a more melee
perspective it was so so slow not we
expected at all
in response to how the competitive melee
community brought the game into a
complicated and technical display of
skill soccer eyes simplified brawl
wavedashing and l cancelling were gone
entirely and while there were some
advanced movement techniques the game
was much slower and every - gave you an
entirely random chance of tripping and
being punished for trying to move
quickly on top of that the game's
balance was something of a mess melee
was top-heavy but no character in that
game was as overpowered as Meta Knight
oh very nice PowerShell hopefully Ally
doesn't choke he can definitely bring
this back mew2king what a great mix-up
going behind him for the grab and
finally kills him yo mr. King is the
winner of MLG 2010 Orlando the entire
meta game revolved around Meta Knight
and there were even serious discussions
of banning him competitively melee fans
gave brawl a chance but the game just
didn't appeal to them I'd say like
summer of that year not even too long
after its release that's when people
most people started to realize at least
people that have gone to melee
Tournament said this is not a legit game
for tournaments so that's about when I
stopped Evo the biggest fighting game
tournament in the world added melee in
2007 but swapped it out for brawl in
2008 and ran it with random stages and
items on this led to a complete unknown
defeating Ken the greatest melee player
in the world in the grand finals
[Applause]
Bayley entered something of a dark age
in 2008 newer players were drawn to
brawl but the diehards couldn't stand it
nearly a year went by without a single
major melee tournament until a player
named Alou card ran a revival of melee
in March 2009 a full year after the
release of brawl melee looked like was
on his death throes it's like you know
let's just do one more
yes farewell our om brought some of
Malee's finest back from obscurity and
helped the community persevere they
founded some of smashes biggest
tournaments from Genesis to Apex and as
the old guard began to fade away a new
generation of melee masters rose to take
their place the five gods you - king
armada mango hungrybox and ppmd
dominated the melee scene after the
release of brawl one of those five won
every single tournament that at least
two attended from 2008 to 2015
their incredible play unbelievable
consistency and absolute dominance
helped usher Mele into a new golden era
they were exciting to watch if they did
double blind right oh that is a monster
tipper he's not gonna be this tough
rattle Randall was there at the exact
moment entertaining personalities the
kings and a nation and brewing because
bleacher King the mega bus and the Fire
Nation attacked
and most importantly incredible at the
game
the community rallied around the five
gods and the attention they brought the
game help the community grow again in
2013 the melee community came out on top
in a charity fundraising competition to
get a spot on the Evo main stage with
nearly ninety five thousand dollars
raised for cancer research melee was set
to appear at evil again for the first
time in six years but at the last second
Nintendo stepped in and tried to derail
everything and remember Nintendo
actually said you can't stream it like
like literally like a day before Evo
started they're like sorry you can't
stream it I remember seeing that on my
phone right when I was about to get on
the airplane and I was like you can't Oh
Nintendo what are you doing the day
before the tournament Nintendo demanded
that Evo not stream it it was their
right as the games publisher but a right
they never exercised before and members
of the community got up in arms Nintendo
has taken it away from the fans
literally saying that Evo can hold the
tournament but you can't actually host
the game this is freaking ridiculous you
can't even they can't stream now like
luckily for melee fans their outcry was
enough to get Nintendo to back off and
even sponsor the tournament but it was
yet another sign of the rift between the
company and the community keeping their
game alive Evo 2013 was the biggest
melee had ever seen with 709 entrance
and played a pivotal role in its
long-standing success I'll say James
Chen and it's been an honor it's been a
great week and I'm behalf the smash
community again thank you to the entire
your staff for keeping us in their minds
letting us seize this opportunity and
make the most of it
melee was growing once again and this
time not even a whole new smash game
could stop it
melee was still going strong and brawl
was well on the way out by the time
Nintendo revealed Super Smash Brothers
for three ES and Wii U this time around
though Nintendo and Sakurai wanted to
make a few more concessions to the
hardcore audience they tried to chase
away with brawl the game was faster with
online modes that allowed for 1v1
matches with no items Nintendo even held
an invitational tournament before launch
that featured some of melee and brawls
best
one by bra pro zero the invitational set
the tone for the rest of Smash Wars
lifespan it performed better
competitively than brawl and was a
single largest smash tournament of all
time at Evo 2016 Dobson if Ally was in
that squeeze after like he would also
stuck it there it is it the halide but
while it seemed like Sakurai and
Nintendo cared about competitive play
for the first time it just wasn't enough
for melee diehards
I hate smash war I hate it just thinking
about smash four makes me angry the fact
that the games were split across two
versions meant that characters like ice
climbers and pokemon trainer
were cut from the roster due to the 3ds
technical limitations and some of the
DLC characters added to the game
post-launch
upended the meta entirely
[Music]
like she's one of the characters that if
you don't know what you're doing you
will just I lost whoops like that just
that happens like you have to know how
to fight playing like like the most
specifically you have to know how to
play against Bayonetta but most
importantly smash4 was held back by
being on Nintendo's least popular
console ever the Wii U the 3ds version
outsold its console counterpart but the
competitive scene was stuck on Wii U
where the game sold less than any of the
series previous entries that's not to
say smash Ford didn't create incredible
moments in its own right zero the
Invitational champion went on to put
together the greatest win streak in
Smash history if not in all of
competitive gaming and his first defeat
at MLG World Finals 2015 made for an
amazing end to a storyline that helped
build Smash 4 into a serious competitive
game one was that you can use the chat
right now they weren't what was that
this is looking amazing for narrow link
does not have the answer today
[Music]
smash for continued to bring in
incredible talent from zero to narrow to
M Kao and more all pushing the game as
far as it could go
you can no longer safely sighs oh my god
that was that was less than 45 seconds
that was a topple third and time forward
smash on this management platform but
all the while Mele kept chugging along
growing and evolving as a years went on
and he goes putting up and throw up here
this time it hits and we have our
champion mango err not that's it
love it wins limpid makes the comeback
he beats all four gods in the wake
while zero dominated smash [ __ ] the
five gods of melee duked it out over the
top spot in the scene our motto was on
top for years until hungrybox stepped up
and finally ended his reign
and just a few years later leffen the
Godslayer who defeated all five gods
years before he rose to prominence
finally won the game's top prize today
the two games coexisted in peace but
they were completely separate one
competitive community that got to play
nice with Nintendo and one that was more
distant and for the first time ever
Nintendo actually wanted to change that
smash fours biggest problem was
something that Nintendo just couldn't
fix no matter how many patches they
issued and so shortly after wrapping up
smash wars DLC soccer I got to work on
his biggest project yet a smash game
that would dwarf all others and possibly
even bring all the smash communities
together for the casual fans that meant
bringing back every character in smash
history alongside a few new ones and the
first single-player mode since brawl for
the competitive smash players that meant
making a game that was faster better
balanced and had more online options
than ever before of course things
weren't perfect
the online smash brothers ultimate is
still the worst all in my opinion of
these for its time is the worst online
slash matchmaking I have ever seen by a
triple-a developer and this is a
triple-a developer so 11 in 11 days 3
million copies but whether it was the
plan or not the game launched to acclaim
from all sides casual fans smash 4
players and melee veterans despite the
shorter development cycle the reused
assets and the relatively small amount
of new content compared to previous
smash games ultimate was
and impossible for even the melee
community to ignore I feel like this
game like the new smash it's already
better than smash where if you asked me
I personally prefer to smash forward by
quite a bit
Super Smash Brothers ultimate is not
melee and likely never will be many top
melee players won't be making a full
time switch anytime soon but the game is
fast and complex enough to satisfy both
smash 4 and melee fans to some extent
and the early days of the competitive
scene have seen players from both thrive
on top of that it's proven to be a
success for the casual smash crowd with
over 12 million copies sold as of
January 2019 it has become the fastest
selling Nintendo game of all time
finally soccer I gave the community a
game that can cater to every type of
Smash fan Sakurai's philosophy of making
a fighting game that anyone can
understand still lives on in ultimate
but for seemingly the first time the
concessions made to competitive players
are enough to unite the disparate smash
communities even if only for a brief
moment the antagonism between Sakurai
and the competitive scene is finally in
the past
you
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]